you only have people over for
Thanksgiving so that they bring stuff to
the buffet and then you bring your pie
you bring five pies you eat for them you
let the other one go hey guys i'm abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen I love
pumpkin pie I love pumpkin pie is what I
live for all year long it's the most
important part of Thanksgiving
oh yeah there's friends and family there
too but really let's be honest it's all
about the pie for that once per year
indulgence I'm gonna go pull out on I
want like a flaky buttery crust and a
satiny full-fat filling and a militant
whipped cream but I know that you know
Thanksgiving is also about sharing and
caring friends and family and I have a
lot of friends and family who have
dietary restrictions right I don't have
time to be making like 4 different
desserts for each and every one of them
so this is where my pumpkin pie parfait
really comes into play it is one
delicious naturally dairy-free recipe
but you can easily adapt to make
Lewton free or vegan and gluten-free so
everyone can get in on the Thanksgiving
fun so let's get to it all right so I
just soaked some cashews overnight in
the fridge
and I'm just gonna puree them until they
kind of reach a grainy like consistency
now I'm gonna add in the kind of cream
from the top of the coconut milk can and
I just set this in the freezer just so
it's modified and made it easy to get
that cream off the top then I'm gonna
add in our pumpkin some maple syrup
coconut oil
a little vanilla
pumpkin pie spices now we curate
okay so into a food processor or the
same blender that you just used I'm
gonna put in some pitted dates and I'm
going to process these until they
a fine means licenses so now I'm going
to add in my cookies some cinnamon
and then I'm gonna process this until it
reaches a sticky crust like consistency
so with the gingersnaps just make sure
that they are vegan there's no dairy or
eggs in them or honey most are but you
just always want to check okay so in a
medium saucepan
I just put about an inch of water into
it on about medium-high heat and we're
gonna bring this customer and then I'm
gonna set the bowl of my stand mixer or
any kind of fruit bowl over top add in
my egg whites
sugar
and a little bit of cream of tartar all
right so we're just going to whip this
business lead but we're looking for
specific result it just turns white
t-shirt get nice ribbons in there and
when you touch the ring
eventually you get no sugar granules to
Tippie all dissolved no need
so we're gonna add in our vanilla and
then we're gonna beat this until it's
light and fluffy and old stiff - let's
do it
we got some music up in here
like a icicles business
okay guys so now we get to assemble and
we're gonna do four different versions
starting with the ultimate
all right now next we'll do the
gluten-free
okay now it's time to do the vegan
version
and finally we've got to do a version
that is good for people who are gluten
free and then be done
so thank you guys so much for watching
if you like this recipe of course give
me the thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen
you